[Music]
hey what's up everyone
welcome back to another culture binge
the wisecrack podcast where we get
all types involved and what's going on
in the cultural zeitgeist
i am michael as always with wisecrack
researcher
serbie how are you today serbia hi i'm
will how are you
good and with wisecrack head honcho and
man of mystery alec alec
how are you this fine morning i'm doing
good
fantastic um lots of fun stuff to talk
about
today we'll get into you know what to do
if you want to end a relationship during
a pandemic
uh we'll give you some tips on the
perfect diet and we'll talk a bit about
some drama
related to nintendo but before we get
into it
we're gonna try something a little bit
new we've decided that we're not feeling
very negative today
or maybe better put we've decided that
there's so much a general negativity
what's the point of getting into it
so we're not doing chaps this time
around so i simply want to ask both of
you
what's something that slaps what's
something you're enjoying what's
something you recommend let's just keep
it positive
serbia start with you all slaps no chaps
i am really enjoying emily and paris on
netflix
it's just so happy and it's light and
it's fun
and there's so many beautiful scenes
that take place in paris
um it's just gorgeous so i highly
recommend it if you feel like you
want to travel from the safety of your
home
yeah i mean i'll second that and just
say it's both um the best and the worst
show i've ever seen
as a television show and piece of
cinematic art it is
just horrible as a way to spend time
binging a show it was incredible made my
entire weekend and i have so many
thoughts about it
so good calls i've only seen two
episodes so no spoilers
oh my god just wait i almost just gave a
big spoiler too i'm glad you said that
uh alec how about you uh
i really enjoyed i just finished the
lovecraft country book now
i have mixed feelings about the show i
really like the first episode i don't
know how i feel about other parts of it
but the book is way better i'm sorry
uh check it out great um
okay i'll say my big thing that's been
slapping in my life
is i'm loving the new wave of like
writers journalists
having their little like subscription
sub-stacked thing
and there's two in particular that i
love that i'm so glad i subscribed to
that i get to read every day um heated
which is one
on uh climate change and science by the
author emily atkin that runs it
and then the discourse which is by a
bunch of writers that used to
run a website called splinter that got
shut down by some evil business goons
and both of these are just super fun i
enjoy reading them and it's nice to uh
subscribes to newsletters is what you're
telling us
listen we can judge or we can consider
me someone who
you know cares about being informed and
also directly
supporting people you know so i'm saying
if you feel like directly supporting
people
you know subscribe to a newsletter or
join our patreon i don't know who am i
to tell you to live your life
um but yes that that's that um
so hopefully you enjoyed those if you're
in the chat right now let us know
what you think slaps right now no chaps
just positivity this time around
but to get started um alec i feel like
you have
some breaking news in the nintendo front
what are you talking about today is it
breaking so people
uh some people are mad about nintendo
and it's funny because i didn't know
uh people were mad even though i had
played the game that people are mad
about so
uh nintendo released for the switch
mario 30 super mario bros 35
which you know super mario brothers i'm
sure many of you have played it
it's that battle royale you're competing
against people there's all these little
squares i tried to play i was very bad
at it i was very confused this isn't
about
necessarily how bad i am about that game
but
uh the real story is and this is from an
npr article that i think
uh will be in the description uh in 2019
a youtuber
uh named inferno plus had an idea to
make super mario brothers into a battle
royale game
uh you raced through levels competing
against other players until everyone
else loses it was called super mario
royale
two weeks after its release he uh they
were told to
take it down by nintendo lawyers so he
removed all the mario ip and rebrand it
as dmca royale for those who don't know
that's a
reference to the digital millennium
copyright act
uh nintendo was still mad about dmca
royale and forced him to take that down
as well
so that's 2019 a year later aka a few
weeks ago nintendo
took the idea and released the game that
many of us with nintendo online are now
playing
uh so maybe they stole the idea
maybe nintendo owns the rights anyway um
so there's an interesting context here
which is that this is not in some weird
vacuum nintendo has a very long history
of issuing takedowns to fan-made games
uh
mp the npr article cites 562 examples
uh many of them are not sold for profit
this is just you know someone
wants to make a cool thing takes a 30
year old game
gives it online player or maybe there's
a fan translation
there's a lot of very notable examples
so if you've heard of super mario maker
where you can make your own mario levels
and have other other people play it
it is alleged to be based on a project
from a fan developer called full screen
mario
fans also translated a sequel to the
game earthbound uh i believe it was
called mother three
um that was only available in japanese
nintendo was not releasing it for years
and years and years and so they
translated themselves and made it you
know available on the internet
um and also what this article goes over
is that
fans have served as like historical
archivist to old video games
you know when nintendo was uh the
original nintendo there was like a glut
of games by all these
small publishing companies that would go
out of business and no one would hear
about the games ever again
and if it weren't for people basically
pirating them on the internet there
would be no record of those so there's
like a weird historical function though
and you know uh nintendo's often going
to combat
these people as well and so i guess the
the the conversation i want to have here
is kind of about copyright in general
but also how evil or not evil nintendo
is
um i wouldn't necessarily say i'm
categorically anti-copyright but i would
say i'm very against our current
copyright system there's a lot of dumb
[ __ ] going on sherock holmes's
descendants are suing
the creators of the anoa home show
because it's the nice version of
sherlock instead of the mean version of
sherlock
and i just don't think that like you
should be able to profit off your great
granddad's
you know book that he wrote almost 100
years ago
um obviously there's there's all the
disney stuff where they're making
remakes of the lion king that no one
asks for so that their copyright on it
or trademark doesn't expire
uh and so there's that
and for nintendo it's not 100 years old
but we're talking about a 30 plus year
old game
should they have the right to sort of
control
in that way or should the fans have more
free reign
i'm a fan of open source uh
projects so i think that it would be i i
like the idea of fans having
the power to contribute to something and
to make it their own
i think if anything it helps the brand
it helps people
um stay engaged and interested in a
product and
i don't see i don't see the downside of
it i mean you're
you're not it's not like you're gonna
lose that much market share that much
money from something like that
yeah yeah and it seems like for a
company like nintendo
that just has like old money long money
fat money short money big money just
like money that's making money you know
like they're not going to go broke
why not and i think if it increases
in a sense it's still like a free type
of marketing and increasing the cultural
cachet
of their intellectual property and using
interesting ways
and i think it makes you look cooler as
a company just from like a marketing
standpoint
i think for nintendo to just say like
yeah like have some fun with it we're
not going to be cops about it
is don't be a cop yeah it's like cool
on their part i can see on the flip side
if it was like
a really small independent game
production house that was
a few friends right out of school that
didn't have a lot of money or startup
capital
and if their idea got taken and used and
became a thing sure
but it's hard to feel bad for nintendo i
guess then the issue is
how does one legislator control that is
it like
up into a certain point you know be cool
and don't steal people's ideas but once
you have world historic money all bets
are off
i i also think you know when someone
like the
original developers of mario like i want
they made a game like
it makes me happy when creative people
like that you know succeed and sort of
reap
a lot of like financial reward you know
it's not
when the the indie developers who made
among us are now probably making
millions of dollars
i'm not like how dare they make millions
of dollars i'm happy for them at the
same time like i think they got that
money and like in 30 years from now
should they still be able to like sort
of
milk the dead bones of among us and i
think same thing with mario especially
in a world where
a lot of the people who worked on that
maybe uh
are not being compensated you know i
know it's simpler
back then but games hundreds of people
work on them and it's not like they're
getting the royalties
you know 30 40 50 years down the line
it's it's nintendo that's getting it and
i think
uh another part of this
is that um
sorry go ahead
oh i had nothing did i look like i was
about to talk no no no i just completely
yeah i i had a brain fart and
was was uh punching it off to you all
i think i think this sort of thing when
like disney and nintendo and companies
like this do that if anything i think it
turns fans away from the brand
and it makes you feel like you
you don't care about your fan base and
you don't want to engage them
and i i just don't see it i mean i
understand the idea of wanting to
protect your intellectual property but
but if anything they're just isolating
themselves from the people who are
making the money
yeah it's like why i stopped thinking
metallica was cool in the
late 90s when drummer lars ulrich sued
napster
for letting people download their music
and i was just like used to be like a
cool
metal adjacent band and now you're just
some old guy
like being mean to 15 year olds getting
your music for free and you're already
metallica you have money you fill arenas
maybe be chill
and i think that it can make people look
lame and crusty in the same way
and corporations look like that yeah i
think another component of this someone
in the chat brought up modding which
was a thing that came to mind is that
people are constantly
uh with with video games like making new
maps they're putting on new skins like
skyrim is famous you know you can play
skyrim as if it's in dragon ball z
and i think you know games are often
um accepting of modding communities
but it's also in this weird space where
if something does so well they can they
can profit off it when i also feel like
there needs to be
kind of like what you're saying a a
tolerance or like a sort of open source
culture of like
listen people can make old mario mods
you know don't do
in such a way that makes it impossible
for nintendo to exist in a company
obviously we can't have a million
bootleg mario games that are competing
with our current games
but in the world where modders are doing
this sort of more open source kind of
stuff or modding a game
you know maybe if we do want to use that
uh then maybe we should give you some
money uh another example
in here that i think is a little bit
more uh of a gray area is there was a
metroid remake that somebody made
you know just updating the graphics and
stuff and nintendo hadn't done it but
then they
did a takedown notice and then they sort
of did their own remake
now i don't know if they did the remake
because of the success of that remake if
they already wanted to
um but but this was the sort of earlier
point that i started
to trail off on is that you know
obviously people
there's work going into putting new
skins and better graphics on the mario
games when you
re-release them um but is that really
like the sort of creativeness
that copyright is supposed to protect or
could anybody have done that and also
been compensated in a fair way yeah and
like with the metroid example
it would just be cool then if nintendo
was like hey you did this thing we
haven't done we'll like
pay you to use yours or buy the rights
to your thing to release it or something
like that that seems like that'd be a
cool move
not that i expect a company to ever be
like cool or do cool things but
they could yeah people people in the
chat are like well it's your property
and
yeah exactly like i agree that listen
i'm not saying that
sony should be able to make mario games
and be like uh you don't have any right
to that i
i think nintendo you know i love you
know all the content that they make and
i think they should still do that
but i think they should make money off
their intellectual property by making
new stuff instead of
you know [ __ ] with people who are i
just think there's a cut-off that's not
a hundred years i don't know if it's 30
years i don't know if it's 20 years
where it's like
fine and i think this is the problem
with hollywood by the way is that you
have actors who did one cool thing and
now they do nothing
while they subsist off royalties of a
cool thing they did 30 years ago i'm
sorry
i was thinking about that the other day
how actors do that um
but yeah i mean i think if you think
about the analog of music often it's the
case where if a younger artist
covers a song by an older artist
obviously they get like a
you know bit of the publishing royalties
or whatever it is but normally they're
kind of like
cool about that think it's interesting
even think of it as like a
a tribute to be covered by a younger
artist so in a sense if i'm
nintendo it's like a testament and a
tribute to my lasting influence as a
company
that people still want to mod and remake
my stuff i don't know i think there's a
way in which it can be seen as like
a tribute and an honor and not like
stealing or
or like appropriating intellectual
property but it's a tricky area and i
get what people are saying that like
they own it so i view it as an
enhancement
like if you want people to keep playing
your game like
why wouldn't you want continuous
improvement to it
yeah especially if it's for free i mean
you know if someone's
for instance the the archive of old
nintendo games like yeah they had
advertisements on there but i mean
again i feel like if nintendo just
stepped in it's like hey you can keep
doing this just give us a cut i'd be
like okay that seems fair
just be cool nintendo yeah i think
that's a good
overall thing here just be cool yeah
um anything else on this one or anything
else in the chat you wanted to
to address on this topic alec we got a
few donations thanks
to cracked prince nez uh having an
uncompromisingly lovely day
thank you uh also the dude is buys dude
abides as always thank you so much
thank you and i'll say yeah judy bide
says he's i think this is maybe his slap
learning how to cook
watching babish culinary on youtube and
making harry potter's butter beer that's
awesome
um and yeah i'll say that's great and if
you're if you're
if you know how to cook learn how to
cook great life skill everyone should
know how to cook um
great well before we move on to the next
topic um just a quick reminder
if you enjoy this podcast if you listen
to this podcast
please subscribe on whatever you use
itunes
spotify stitcher there's probably other
ones i don't know them off the top of my
head
but it would mean a lot to us if you
subscribe and review so
leave a review you know i said this
before at one point i said
let us know in the review who would play
each of us if a film adaptation got made
about culture binge
um you could go for that one or maybe
you could associate each of us with a
fast food restaurant in the review so
let us know you think about it and say
if alec was a fast food chain
which one would he be if serbia was a
fast food chain i know it's hard to
imagine there's a fast food chain
because she's more fine dining
restaurant what would she be
if i was a fast food chain and i'm more
like food on the side of the road what
would i be
so let us know that give us five stars
it means a lot to us and honestly
it helps us a lot so if you can take a
second to do that
we'd really appreciate it um and i just
want to know what fast food restaurants
we are
so speaking of fast food and eating
unhealthy trash food
i wanted to talk a little bit today
about the
optimal human diet um it might have been
discovered
i i find this kind of interesting
because now that i'm just a disgusting
old man i'm interested in health
so there was an article that our lovely
uh producer joy pointed out to us that
was on a medium blog
uh called the nuance uh and the writer
mark am hyde
wrote an article called science might
have identified the optimal
human diet which pointed to a research
study
um by someone named james o'keefe in the
journal
of the american college of cardiology
and this study was looking into what the
optimal human diet would be
largely in terms of things like
cardiovascular health
propensity towards things like strokes
even depression and stuff like that
so the main gist of this study
was that the best diet for human persons
is a pesco mediterranean diet um
which consists of well so in general
we've probably heard of the
mediterranean diet which is basically
just like
what people in like southern italy and
greece and stuff eat
fish yes [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah um thanks for you know
taking all my steam there alex uh i'm
kidding so yeah but like alex said
it's a diving system things like plants
nuts extra virgin olive oil
um seafood and has a strong cardio
protective evidence
meaning good for your heart builds a
little shield around it um so along with
the pesco mediterranean diet they also
discovered
that time restricted eating is a central
component of this diet
another term for that people use their
intermittent fasting right now
so the study shows that the ideal diet
then is a mix of pesco mediterranean
mediterranean diet with a eating window
of 8 to 12 hours meaning that if you
have your first meal
at 10 a.m you finish at six or
alternatively if you eat
your first meal at 8 a.m you have your
last meal at 8 p.m
something like that um now
one thing i liked about their framing of
this diet
is that it's a lot less restrictive than
a lot of things because along with
the the pesco mediterranean thing in the
study it says
so mostly have vegetables extra virgin
olive oil and nuts
then have a good amount of fish then you
know occasionally have some eggs maybe
some cheese some chicken
and then they're like red meat special
occasions not so much
and then in terms of beverages they say
water
sparkling or still coffee or tea
unsweetened
or red wine one glass for women two
glasses for men
i don't make the rules i think that's
kind of messed up uh you know i think
everyone should have have two glasses
but whatever
um but one of the advantages according
to these scientists is it doesn't have a
lot of the intense restrictions that a
lot of fad diets do and
all of the research shows that people
fail
fad diets because of the intense
restrictiveness to them
um so one of the advantages of this one
is it's basically like
eat mostly good stuff sometimes bad
stuff but the main things in the study
they get into which i found really
interesting
um were that the biggest stuff to avoid
are like
fried foods sugars and
processed like flowers and and uh and
like white breads and carbohydrates
and a phrasing that was used in the
study was that a lot of the things
regularly eaten by americans like fried
foods
sugars and like white carbs are toxic to
the human body
and that language really stood out to me
so i don't know i found it
i just found this an interesting study
in general a bold claim that this is the
ideal
human diet but something that is
interesting and we can link to the
scientific study as well
now i'm not a scientist but i can read
charts and there's some charts in the
study
of a good chart very convincing yes and
the thing that
i found the most interesting was so they
you know did a
pretty thorough study on this and they
showed in terms of morality
sorry morality mortality not morality
they didn't show who's more moral on the
diet
but in terms of mortality and in heart
disease mortality
the pesco vegetarian diet which is their
version of the pesco mediterranean one
was just as healthy
if not healthier than straight up
veganism
so let's say hypothetically you're
someone
who is worried about heart health or
runs in your family and you think i
gotta go full vegan if i want to live to
see my grandkids and play
mods of mario with them um this study
shows
that by certain metrics the pesco
vegetarian diet is just as healthy now
morality is another thing
there's plenty of good moral reasons to
be a vegan shouts to alec
but um oh okay
wait aren't you though are you
vegetarian vegetarian yeah but i'm
vegetarian sorry i
i i don't eat a ton of cheese but anyway
okay yeah we don't want you on blast
here but either way
found it interesting um and also i find
it interesting
uh that not interesting but like
a cool idea that a diet like this
opens you up to a lot of possibilities
without the restrictions of a lot of the
fad diets that like you can
learn about on goop.com um
what do you all think about the perfect
diet i have many thoughts
i know you do so you're about to rip
this apart so yeah get into it well i
should preface this by saying like
it's not all [ __ ] however i will
also get into
like when you sent this i was very very
suspicious
because a lot of health journalism is
bad and also like diet research is
historically bad and it's
bad for a few reasons one is that most
of the studies you know you can follow
people for you know there's kind of two
kinds of studies you can follow people
for
a couple weeks change their diet but you
know when it comes to heart health that
obviously occurs over several years
that's one problem
the other kind of study is not a
controlled study but sort of
you know interviewing people what's your
diet like looking at sort of their
lifespan heart disease all that stuff
but not a controlled environment so that
data is bad and sorry there's a third
one
which is like a long-term controlled
longitudinal study
and that's really expensive to follow
like hundreds or thousands of people and
controlling their diet every single day
for 10 20 30 years
there is one study and so the study that
was linked is actually it's like
mostly it's not even like a
meta-analysis it's just talking about
other studies to make an argument um and
it
talks about the only longitudinal one
for the mediterranean diet
the long-term one is it's called like
the predamed study
and apparently it has all like a ton of
problems which you read about there's
there's a vox article that sort of gets
into this a little bit
um but just like a lot of methodological
problems now the criticism of it isn't
that the mediterranean diet is like full
of [ __ ]
but it's just like we really shouldn't
be propping up this study as the gold
standard when there's like lots and lots
of problems with it
and also like any time you do data about
diet
there's so many confounding factors you
know like talk about the mediterranean
diet who are people
that like eat a lot of fish which is
kind of expensive and like a lot of
extra virgin olive oil
in america you know that is often
correlated with
like having more money and we also know
that having more money correlates to
better health
or if you want to get geographical like
certain european countries the better
health care systems
or sort of other cultural practices now
i don't think it's all [ __ ] because
obviously
you know as one commenter in the
commenter com in the comment section
noted
people have been harping on how bad the
american diet has been for like a
century which is true yeah
we just our food culture we eat like
[ __ ] uh and not a lot of other
countries do that
oh we don't eat like [ __ ] it's not
our fault but go ahead
well yeah well yeah i mean i mean
there's like a lot of historical things
that go into
like you know in the early 1900s beef
trust we're selling america the american
public on why we have to eat steak for
every single [ __ ] meal
but uh so i think we should always take
this with a grain of salt there's
science that says you know like people's
there is not sort of a
one one uh diet fix all
solution for everyone people are
different people have different levels
of activity
you know if you're a through hiker you
probably need to have a
drastically different diet than someone
who sits in a chair all day like i do
obviously there's concerns about like if
you have a family history of heart
disease or diabetes or things like that
and so i just always [ __ ] hate
journalism that's like the diet that we
figured out fixes everything
well yeah yeah well i'll just say that
like the main article i'm working on
here
isn't journalism it's scientific study
that we got linked to through a
journalistic article
but i'll just say this there i the thing
i really appreciate about the long study
is it had so many qualifications that i
thought were important even getting into
like white rice
and like flour-based pastas and stuff
that a lot of people say are just bad
they're like no actually it's pretty
good if you prepare it this way blah
blah blah blah
and i do think like i think you're right
when we think about
i guess like the sociology of people
that eat this stuff whenever we think
about let's say a mediterranean diet or
even like european diets we're talking
about people that probably walk a lot
more
than your average american so that
factors into it as well
um so yeah i think there's of course a
lot of factors here
but in general i think the reason why i
still think this is an interesting
approach or more interesting than a lot
of stuff
the basic gist of it is like eat mostly
vegetables fruits and nuts and stuff
and yeah a little amount of all the all
the bad stuff yeah
i think yeah vegetables rip and i think
you know like the more involved like the
scientific
study um isn't it it doesn't say like
you know this is the best diet ever and
there's if we can link to the
the study i think one of the most
important things about it is they have
an illustration that's the pesco
mediterranean
mediterranean saying that mediterranean
i swear i'm not high
pesco mediterranean diet pyramid and
just visually
i wish you were all looking at it right
now too it's just very helpful because
it's just like
a standard diet pyramid easy to make
sense of and i do think something that
most people could do
what do you guys well serbia i wanna
hear what you think in general but i
also wanna know what you guys think
about the intermittent fasting element
of this the idea of like
eating in a constricted window so i've
actually been trying to move towards
this diet
um because i have quite a few food
allergies so this
like type of diet works well with what
i'm allergic to
um and i have felt
healthier and i've done nothing more
like i've
i like still do nothing at home i don't
exercise i don't do anything
um but i feel a lot better uh maybe
because i'm not eating like cheese
eight times a day um but
i for me it helps i think like alex said
or one of you said it depends on your
body it depends on your health
you can't like prescribe one thing for
everyone because we all have different
health considerations
um i i have
noticed though that it is very expensive
to eat this way
um and it's not for everyone and even
i'm like
okay that's like way too expensive for
me
um yeah so if this is the kind of thing
that's
for people who can budget out a
significant amount of money
for for food um
and then your question about
intermittent fasting i've tried it
it's horrible i would get heartburn
during the day like if people were like
like i did one where it was like oh
don't
like don't eat like skip one day
skip one day of food a week or something
and only have one meal that day
yeah so i tried that it was awful i was
so tired i had the worst heartburn
and then i tried the whole like eat only
eight hours a day
um and i i just think i kept looking at
like it made me feel pressured
to like fit in all my food i felt like i
was binge eating
yeah i did like that this study said 12
hours is the wider range of that because
to me that doesn't sound
unreasonable to have like breakfast at 8
or 9
and then finish dinner by 8 or nine at
night like that's not crazy
um the eight hours is rough though i i
don't know so
one thing the study though was not a
study it was like a review of existing
literature
which i think suffers but anyway on
intermittent fasting there's a really
good
there's a really no it wasn't a
meta-analysis which is different because
that's like running stats but anyway
uh the intermittent fasting i think was
interesting there's a really good
science
versus the podcast uh with wendy
zuckerman
anyway uh they do it and so she's going
to have a better job of whatever i'm
about to say because i i'm
sort of reaching here i think there
might be certain benefits of
intermittent fasting for certain medical
conditions where like you can you know
people have done the controlled studies
like you're going to
do this but a lot of the benefits i
think people ascribe to it especially
around weight loss is just
like listen if you tell yourself i can't
eat after six o'clock you're just going
to be eating less food
and then you'll lose weight and so the
question is if you just eat less food
anyway is that the fasting working or is
it just
you know snacking less and i think for
people that that works for
you know like if it works for you like
i'm not going to eat after 8 pm i have a
hard and fast rule
and it works and you're going to eat
less fritos like dope
whatever works for you if you're trying
to like reduce your sodium intake
whatever
i think that's great but i don't know if
it's necessarily like
i i i don't know like i i think there's
probably specific research studies about
specific things but i don't know
it's not like in and of itself it's this
magical thing for being healthier
yeah and i think we do have to say just
to be fair to everyone listening
the study i'm referring to did have some
funding from the california walnut
commission so big walnut
has its hands all over this so we just
have to be honest that it could just be
yeah so it could just be that that
walnut money is forcing this
um and really it's like beef and milk is
all we should have to be healthy so
just be aware of the walnut lobby i'm
allergic to walnuts see
now uh the whole thing's been
we broke this case wide open cracked
that nut oh god i hate myself
um so anyway any final thoughts on this
before
we we move on into more romantic
territory
i i will say to not be a marginally
[ __ ] like the thing that i liked
about the article was that
you know restrictive diets don't work
people fall off of them and they like
come back with a vengeance to
[ __ ] eat more food and it's really
you know i
i'm not disagreeing with the idea of
like eat more vegetables and less like
you know and again like i think diet
culture is bad but i think it's fine to
say
like oh you know i'm gonna try to you
know
make a nice big salad and eat a [ __ ] ton
of broccoli without sort of hating
yourself and starving yourself
um so i think that's fine and i i yeah
for people to do that if they want to do
that i have one thing before we move on
do it um i just remembered that so i was
talking to a few friends
who do these sorts of like fad diets and
they stopped doing them because they
said that it sort of
sparked like eating disorders like
disordered eating and things like that
and so they said that as soon as they
start to concentrate on food
you really start to limit yourself and i
think that happened to me when i was
doing the
uh the fasting thing like i i felt like
i was binge eating
when i could eat and i also felt like i
was like restricting
food intake because i was like oh no
like i shouldn't be eating that much
cheese i mean obviously
you want to like limit the amount of
cheese you eat but there were other
things where i was like oh no i
shouldn't i shouldn't eat that or i
shouldn't do this so i do feel like
there's a fine line between doing
something for your health and then
taking it to an extreme so be careful
everyone
well yeah i think i'll give the last
word on this to michael pollan
uh who i think said something really
smart in his book i think it's in the
omnivore's dilemma when he just says
like
eat food mostly vegetables not too much
and i truly think like he really gets it
a lot there and he also says in how to
change your mind
do psychedelics in safe settings not too
much
so i like this guy's advice eat
vegetables be safe about it do
psychedelics be safe about it he seems
happy and healthy
um so speaking of happy
and healthy in terms of human and
interpersonal relationships
last time serbia you got into the world
of
dating and sort of starting
relationships yes in the context of a
pandemic
now you're just jumping to the end of
the book and you want to talk about the
problem
or possibility of ending these
relationships during a pandemic
so i think we're excited to hear about
this let's get into it okay so the
pandemic has been hard on all of us
whether it's impacted our health
our schooling our work our social life
whatever we've all been impacted in some
way by covid19
and for those of you who are in a
relationship
specifically those of you who live with
a partner this has
created a unique situation for you
because you you no longer have any
separation between you
and your significant other it's your
constant companion
you can't escape during the work hours
you can't go to dinner
they're right there and recently i've
been hearing a lot of stories about
people who are trying to figure out
whether or not they want to break up
with their partner but the problem is
that they don't know if it's
pandemic induced or whether their
relationship has just reached its
natural conclusion
and yesterday i was talking to a friend
who's been with her boyfriend for three
years
and she said that they've both realized
they want to break up
but they're reluctant because before
march of this year
things were going really well they were
talking about getting married they were
talking about making all these
significant life plans
and now they feel like they have
all of this stress and fear and they're
unsure whether that is impacting
how they interact with each other so
neither one wants to live together or be
together but they're also like should we
wait it out like should we see
should we give it another six months
like maybe things will be better if we
can
go back to work and go back to normal
life another scenario i've heard
is people in a relationship
and they know this person's not a
long-term
relationship but they don't want to be
alone
and so they say is it better to be with
someone i casually like someone i like
enough
rather than be alone and be isolated
right now
and the new york times recently
published an article entitled
should you break up and it provides
several great questions
that you should ask yourself if you find
yourself in this situation to determine
whether your feelings are pandemic
induced
or just relationship induced and some of
the questions are like
if the world were fine again would you
still want to be with this person or has
the way that you have the way you two
argue has that changed since the
pandemic
or when you have to compromise or
negotiate on something do you feel like
you're losing ground
and i know the two of you are in
relationships and you live with your
significant others and i don't want to
ask you like personal
like getting for now by the end of this
segment i might leave i mean
that's why i brought up this article um
what are your thoughts on this like
whether
you want to talk about yourself or
friends or whoever like do you have you
also heard that people are struggling
with their relationships yeah well first
of all i think your friends
should go to couples counseling first
because if they
are having a hard time but they were
like we were good before maybe before
you pull the rip cord go to couples
counseling
but i will say this i won't say how i
know it i do know right
now where i live um it's
most couples counselors are backed up so
i think
so i think that says something about the
current moment we're living in
um and i do think like something that's
paramount in our relationship at least i
find this i don't know anything
but is i feel like relationships go
better when individual partners
have their own lives and have places
they find
value meaning and purpose outside of the
relationship itself so they're not
putting all their weight on that thing
and i do think and i read an article
about this somewhere i forget where
but it was about codependence and
relationships growing
uh during coveted 19. i think all of us
know that
it's not good to be in a co-dependent
relationship so i feel like
that is a thing that is happening that's
hard to manage when you have especially
if you're
in a relationship where you take like
pandemic stuff seriously so you're not
out and about with a bunch of other
people and going to bars and stuff like
that
i think it's it's hard and i would
almost be
i would be less trustworthy of someone
who was like yeah
me and my partner have largely just been
together for six months and we're just
crushing
like i would think they were lying and
they wanted to kill each other
um whereas i think how how can you
not have some tension or be a little bit
overwhelmed being around the same person
day in day out for six months shouts to
my partner i love her very much i uh
so i'm skeptical of ideas like soul
mates and you know i think a lot of
stuff around there uh obviously i very
much like my partner
but uh i kind of have i'm gonna call it
like the materialist conception of
relationships not materialist in terms
of buying [ __ ] but like in the
historical material sense because i'm a
giant [ __ ] nerd
that's the theory that like history's
driven by the sort of material
circumstances of the world and like how
things get made rather than like people
and ideas
but anyway like i think a lot of
relationships if they do or don't work
it's often because of like
the the various material circumstances
of the relationship and i don't mean
money i mean like their jobs and
where they live and what's going on and
i think
often times when relationships end this
isn't the only reason obviously
like things change like they have kids
and then you sort of like change the
very environment
of like what that relationship is and
you realize like you don't necessarily
like that thing or you get older
or you retire and you have to spend all
day with them or
you know you you know
want to move to a different city or
something like that and so i think with
the the pandemic it's basically
redefining everyone's relationship you
know maybe you were more
casual you were a couple that had very
distinct lives you were going to bars
and this is a person that
you love to hang out with you know see
every day and loved for
you know a couple hours a day and spend
more time on weekends together or maybe
you were shut-ins who spent every single
day and nothing has really changed but i
think
like just because you buy into one thing
doesn't necessarily
mean that you're down for the rest and
so i i feel like for people
breaking up is it that they've fallen
out of love with the person or is it
just that they
like weren't they're not into this sort
of relationship dynamic and the material
circumstances surrounding it so i'd be
like very nervous because i feel like
when things return to normal maybe
they'd be missing out like on a really
great
relationship that they yeah beforehand
well i think in general i just don't
like the idea of like
making a big decision right now i just
think like whether that be ending a
relationship
or moving or leaving a career or
whatever
i completely understand that impulse but
it seems like a bad time to do any of
those things
and of course i feel like the brackets
for all of this is
if someone is in like a truly messed up
abusive
shitty relationship yes get the hell out
but if it's like a thing that was
working fine before whether that's a job
or a relationship or whatever
i don't know maybe like write it out and
see how things are going
when the world gets a little more normal
i think also it's good to create a
routine
and have us a clear division of when you
want alone time and when you want to
spend time as a partner
yeah uh i will say it's funny though
because
i work from home and you know have free
reign of my
tiny apartment for most of the day
except now that
my partner's also working from home and
just you know uh
i've said this before i think but you
know starts to tells other people is the
the sort of fear of being judged by
other people constantly
all the should i do during the day it's
i mean for a while it was a real
big you know argument point of you know
why do you care how many chips i'm
shoving in my face this is my life leave
me alone
yes uh there's there's things that
happen when you're around each other all
the time i having in trouble sometimes
when it's like oh you were you were
watching
tv during the day and it's like i swear
to god it's for work i don't even like
this show
sometimes you have to do this stuff um
but it's rough it's it's rough to be on
people if anyone has any thoughts on
this too
uh in the chat let us know um i mean
what was your advice to your friends
herbie
uh to try to do therapy if she can get
in to see a therapist
otherwise try um like a trial separation
if she can go stay with her parents or
something
just to have yeah serbia you sound like
you're far away if your microphone moved
or something no i i choked without water
okay cool um cool and everyone you know
serbia's dealing with some some
some heavy stuff on her and she almost
died because of water
and she luckily came back yeah the
mediterranean died don't drink water
just drink processed american lagers
bud light ice only um
yeah i i yeah i do wonder i feel like
the
the end result of this will be that like
certain couples that weren't together
that long are gonna bond really
intensely
get married as soon as this is over and
then get divorced in two years and maybe
some other people
are going to break up prematurely and
then a year later get back together
but we should we should keep up with
your friend and her partner on this one
i want to i want to hear how their
journey is
tell us everything about their life and
where they are
that's the best that's the best that we
can do that um any final thoughts on
this one
before we we move on
good luck if you're in a relationship
yeah
good luck and hey you know what i'll say
this let's say you're in a relationship
let's say you need to vent and you feel
like you have no one to talk to
i know you can talk to us how can you do
that
you can email us or call us now you can
do this event about relationships
to tell us your thoughts on game
modifications or to talk about
you know diet and eating stuff so you
can hit us up at culturebench at
wisecrack.co that's culture image
wisecrack.com
or call us at 213-5348 that's
213-534-8807
full anonymity we won't tell your
partner that you are
lying awake at night thinking about how
you could get out looking at apartments
in another city planning your escape
um but i would say if you're thinking
that do listen to i forget the artist
but the pina colada song or
escape in brackets the pina colada song
because it's a tale about how sometimes
you think you want to get out but you're
already with the person you should be
with
all along so never leave without
listening to the pina colada song
um but speaking of people that vented to
us and told us your deep
deepest darkest secrets i know we have
some emails and voicemails
uh what do you want to start with alec
uh we got some voicemails
this first one is from anonymous
uh can we play that joy see we'll keep
you anonymous
hey culture bench here from a major u.s
city i'm staying anonymous but i just
want to talk a little bit about
dating culture in a major u.s city it's
still happening
um tinder bumble hinge okay cupid you
name it they're booming
um at the beginning the first few months
people were not actually meeting and i
feel like
that was the time when people were kind
of like i'm just not gonna use it
because
why but now people just don't care um me
included i have gone out um
to a date and yeah people um some people
are doing the whole social business
thing some dating apps even have said
like
hey like i'm down to date with a math
like you can specify that in your
profile
but a lot of people are just dating um
they are going to like the parts and
stuff like that but end up hooking up at
home
it's just what's happening but hey
take cover test if you're doing that and
keep safe i don't know but hope y'all
having a great time
thank you uh yeah i've been noticing a
lot of people caring less i think people
should care more but
what do i know yeah that's
that's an interesting one i appreciate
the the
insight and the honesty um i'll say this
though one thing about having friends
that are dating you're in covid this is
going to be kind of mean
but then you don't want to hang out with
them because you know i hang out with
friends sometimes outside
but safely but i have one friend who's
like dating and then
the then it's like well if i hang out
with you you're just dating all these
randoms and like kissing and snuggling
or going home with them or whatever i
don't want
exposure to all that yeah sorry
hopefully that friend isn't listening to
this uh
we also got a comment from dice hazard
uh
asking people to write a daily journal
to wisecrack about your insufferable
significant other
i would i would love that i mean not not
too creepy but i'm
god i just hate slash love stuff like
that
anyway uh our next voicemail is from
who's it from who's it from
somebody joy let's play that one
uh i will tell you in one second so
while yeah
alec is gonna find the email he said
there's the email from cole about
boomer parents hey this message is for
culture binge uh my name is cole i'm a
long time
listener um i am a millennial um smack
dab i think in the middle
and i went to college um way long ago
like a decade and i applied to 33
schools um
my boomer father was really worried that
i guess i wouldn't have focus or
something like that but um
i remember college being a really big
thing at my school my ap
us history not usually my ap government
teacher had a board in the classroom
where all the kids wrote down where
they're going to school
it was like a huge event for everyone
and so it was like really anxiety driven
and a lot of us cited as like the reason
for our problems now so
i wanted to just mention that as an
anecdote um that yeah it's kind of crazy
uh i did i didn't realize that most kids
didn't apply to 33 schools like me
until uh like later on in life when i
started working
um but yeah thanks so much for all that
you guys do uh servie get on that thing
and uh thank you
all alec and uh and the dr sweaty
uh peace doctor sweaty
now he's on your [ __ ] list doesn't he no
no comment
me and michael i don't know about you
serbie uh but
i think i i transferred but i at one
point applied to two colleges
maybe the first time around i applied to
three
i think i applied to like four yeah i
was also broke so that was part of the
fee thing yeah
yeah i only applied to a few um 33
is insane and if i remember correctly
aren't they around like 50 bucks
so to apply sixteen hundred dollars you
can get waivers so
a lot of times if you have like a
certain gpa or
uh test score they waive the application
fee for you
but yeah that's that's wild and i uh
i've been reading the book written by
the author i referenced
last week um in in terms of this topic
the book can't even by anne alan
peterson
and some of the stuff about like younger
millennials and what they go through
in college and college prep is is really
horrible harmful sounding stuff so i'm
glad nicole sounds like he's like
survived and done well but that's crazy
also
pretty uniquely american phenomenon that
we make people pay a bunch of money
to just to be considered for a college
that already costs more than
higher education anywhere else in the
world it's it's wild
that board that he discussed in his ap
gov
class terrifies me it would have given
me so much anxiety to see something like
that i would have felt horrible about
myself
as everybody put like an ivy league
college up there
oh that's rough we didn't have a board
we had stuff like that i just didn't
care
and i i think i i was way too the other
i didn't do my homework i did not care
about my grades and i'm not saying to do
that but i think i escaped that
uh somehow magically uh maybe i should
have applied myself more i think there's
a healthy balance
uh but i'm doing fine uh okay the next
we got some emails again
culture binge at wisecrack.co that's
culture
binge at wisecrack.co there is no m
uh the first email is from m
about dating uh
hello culture binge crew i really agree
with serbi that the proliferation of
digital interaction
during the pandemic has actually driven
people like me away from dating apps
i now more than ever want to forge
romantic relationships more organically
through my in-person network of friends
because i've relied on online dating for
the past six years i actually found it
really difficult to navigate
asking a person out in person in my
opinion
online dating has degraded the courtship
rituals we want to use as admittedly
flawed as they were
and new generations are now often
dependent on dating apps because we have
little practice with expressing or
receiving romantic interest in person
be it to strangers or friends my
question to the culture binge crew my
questions
to the culture binge crew are do you
think online dating has changed in
person courtship
and what new and better rules of
courtship should be established if there
is a post-covet shift
towards in-person romance i mean
it's definitely changed uh the dynamics
of in-person courtship and i just
i mean like i met my current partner at
an era where like
it wasn't weird to kind of just like
start talking to a stranger
and go on a first date when you knew
very little about the other person
um now now just to be 100 clear i do
think that like the advantage of online
dating is it stopped a lot of the
creepiness especially from we'll just
say it
like dudes rolling up on largely like
women
in bars and environments and just being
creep ass well there's still people just
not digitally
well yeah yeah so i'm saying like
they're still dudes are still creepy as
hell but
i guess at least they're creepy in a way
you can like delete them out of your
inbox or something i don't know serbia
knows it's so much better than that
guys are still creepy in person guys are
still creepy online
like they i've had guys that i
didn't connect with on a dating app but
like i would just see them as i was like
scrolling through
and then they would i would see them
show up on my linkedin
like this person viewed your profile and
i never talked to them i never connected
with them
they just happened to see me and like
decided to look me up
um that's creepy if you ever find a
woman on linkedin you're a scumbag never
do that that's
that's a professional networking site
you f creeps sorry that just made me mad
i stalk people on linkedin all the time
not for romantic reasons though linkedin
facebook all the things
it's super creepy so if anything i feel
like the one thing that
online dating has done it's allowed the
creepiest
people who usually exist on the fringes
of society
to come out into the limelight and like
has normalized their behavior like oh
dick pic
yeah okay delete so i
i don't think there's anything good
about that like it's not it's made them
make anything
bolder okay well then that's good i mean
that's not good that's good to hear that
but yeah i don't know i just think you
go to before the pandemic happened
you go to like a bar or coffee shop
these days people just stare at their
phones they don't like talk to each
other
and whenever i've been at like let's say
my neighborhood bar which i hope still
exists at the end of this it probably
won't i'm about to start crying but i
won't
like people don't like if the people
that talk to each other organically tend
to be a bit older and people that are
younger
either with their friends or they stare
at their phones and that bums me out and
i wish there was ways to more
organically interact and meet people and
i hope that comes back
i yeah
i'm i'm not skeptical i think there's
like
pros and cons i think obviously the
online dating is a dumpster fire but i
think
it's almost like i think there's a
bucket of people who might be good for
i think a lot of people go on dating
apps i'm like this is exactly what i'm
looking for if i don't see that i'm not
going to swipe and i think that's like
just a bad
sort of philosophy to dating on the
other hand i think there's people with
social anxiety maybe on their spectrum
et cetera
who are just like would never go up to
yeah
i could say that as a person who you
know before i was in a relationship
would never ever do that the only times
i would ever talk to women's when they
approached me
nice which happened like two times uh so
good job alec hopperman
uh so i don't know
i think everything's bad well
you know what i think both would be good
i think you're i think we used to only
meet people
in person let's say then it swung really
hard the other way where primary
relationship primarily starting
digitally i think like you just pointed
at alec
it'd be good if we had a little bit of
everything where it was appropriate and
culturally normative
to organically meet someone and it was
also totally fine and appropriate to use
apps if that was a better way to do it
but i feel like we need both
i agree i do think that online dating is
good
in the sense that it does expand your
network and introduces you to people who
you wouldn't interact with
in your daily life um but i also think
that
meeting someone organic it's i really
like this email because it
felt like everything that i have wanted
to say but just i said it a lot less
eloquently than m
did um and i think that
if anything like i mentioned in our last
episode i hope that
there is this push towards um
returning back to those old courtship
rituals of like waiting
and like getting to know someone and
there's excitement and there's interest
rather than like
hey do you want to hook up tonight and
netflix and chill
yeah i also just want to say uh no
offense to anyone i think the word
courtship freaks me out that's all
that's it i love the word courtship and
i will continue to use it in
every episode from now on thank you
thank you uh
anyway uh i want to thank uh stacy for
donating thank you so much stacey
thank you stacy the next email is
from
this one is from oh man the tension
builds
who's it gonna be i i label this weird i
think it's from anonymous as well i
think the other one was from
someone named em uh anyway yeah hey
wisecrack firstly i was very sad to hear
that jared is leaving wisecrack we're
all sad
uh but wish him all the best for the
future i hope it is voice-over-related
so i can still hear his silky tones
very silky voice i think we all want
that um i wanted to share my experience
of dating during a pandemic
before lockdown i was unlike alec uh not
a wife guy
near the start of the lockdown i hooked
up with an acquaintance and later with
someone i met on tinder however i met
another girl on tinder and have
been dating since june in the past i
would normally be on the lookout for the
next person to take my fancy weather in
real life or online
but recently i've chosen not to take any
action if i meet see someone i like the
look of
i wonder if the new normal has changed
mine and other people's attitudes to
dating
are we looking for something secure and
consistent in a world that is overtly
threatening and uncertain
i think that's a great idea i mean a
great a great take
what do you think i think that's a
really good take yeah
i think when everything else is going
great in the world and feels stable
i understand why some people might want
to date more casually
and not be locked down that way but of
course when the world
is unstable and chaotic having a stable
relationship can be a nice sort of point
of grounding so that makes really good
sense
i was talking to a couple of my friends
uh the other day and
we were saying that this is not the year
to try something new and different
it's like we crave routine and we crave
like
things that we're used to and i'm like
that's true because
when i was on like target.com and i
needed to order
something i was like now is not the year
to try a new brand of tampons
like let's just go with foreign well i'd
say this though it's not the year to do
that but like
shouts to the comment that dude abides
gave before learning to cook online i
think it is the year
to maybe learn new stuff right to not
like make big life changes
but we have maybe some time and we need
to keep our brains interested without
like new external stimuli so don't try
new tampons do learn new skills
eat new food always yeah try the
mediterranean night
yes only that um any other emails for
this this go around one more for connor
that's our last uh this is about boomer
parents i am 22 and my parents can be
considered millennials
growing up my sister and i weren't
necessarily pushed to attend college but
definitely felt like we had to
my parents were both working fairly
standard jobs and want us basically
us to basically be better than they were
i focused really hard on
education the point that i had very slim
social life
uh and i'm feeling the effects of that
now i went to a community college and
got a degree in programming
but immediately switched career and
education paths to pursue psychology
during the summer before i began my
bachelor's while i'm enjoying my new
education path i still feel fairly lost
as to what i actually want to do i'm
currently pursuing a career in art
therapy but also feel like i've
completely missed out on figuring out
what i really want in life i don't blame
my parents but i do think they had a
role in my desire
to pursue education over figuring myself
out i'm hoping that
when i become a parent down the line
allow my kids to become who they wish to
be
but i fear that might be become like my
parents as well since that seems
to be how generation psychology goes
we basically copy our parents what do
you think
i i got to say this to connor you're a
young man there's time
so don't i just feel like you shouldn't
feel like you haven't figured it out yet
and it's like you're too far gone you
might pursue art therapy which is a
really cool thing when you're 30 you
might do something different and that's
totally fine so just i hope you know
that like you shouldn't be overwhelmed
by this
and it's totally normal i think to be
especially in your early 20s
trying failing and figuring stuff out
and i think in that process
you're going to figure some stuff out
and you're going to be a great parent
one day and you know we're all going to
repeat some of the shitty stuff our
parents taught us you can't avoid it
but don't be hard on yourself no but too
much pressure on yourself and i think
that's normal
sorry for being a little soap boxy but i
just feel for connor
i i also know a lot of people who
studied one thing
changed or went back to school years
later to do another thing i know a lot
of people who got degrees in like
history and english and i think
some of them really value those degrees
but they're like listen i gotta
go to coding boot camp to like actually
get a job and
i just think that's it can often suck
but i i wouldn't say you're
the the exception in any way connor
definitely not
and you shouldn't feel like a failure or
something because you don't have it
figured out
you have your whole life to figure
something out and people switched
careers multiple times
i was going to do law and got into law
school
and when i was 21 i was like wait i
don't actually want to be a lawyer
and it took me years to figure out that
i should do something and i went to
business school and now
i'm thinking about doing a different
career and going back to school
so you you will likely have multiple
careers in your life and it's okay to
try something and figure it out you're
just getting one step closer to what you
actually want to do and at least you're
accumulating a list of what you don't
want
because that's a big thing too a lot of
people don't know what they don't like
and so to figure out that you don't like
programming
that's good like you know that now you
can explore other things
and if you decide to go through uh with
art therapy
and you decide to do a master's degree i
highly suggest doing
uh social work rather than one of the
other like clinical psychology or
something there's
there are a lot more opportunities for
social work from my understanding than
some of the other
um like marriage and family therapy or
clinical psychology
wow free advice and yeah and just
remember like neil armstrong didn't walk
on the moon until he was 77
the beatles met in their 60s steven
spielberg didn't get his first camera
until he was 87.
you can start things late in life none
of those were true in the slightest
um but people love to say stuff like
that they're yeah there's a lot of
people who like
write their first novel when they're 40
and yeah and i don't think writing your
novel should be the [ __ ] metric to go
off of but i think uh
god there's that boslerman song
everyone's pretty wear sunscreen
uh about people not figuring out who
they were until they're 40.
uh i would say also it's not all
career you know hobby hobbies weather
or passions whether it's you know
writing or
painting or going on hikes or i don't
[ __ ] like there's other [ __ ] besides
what you do for work as well
yeah that's a good point yeah it should
be your career shouldn't define who you
are and you shouldn't identify yourself
with your career which is a hard thing
to do especially
like if you you live in the us a lot of
times like that is who you are
but it you should
work so that you can live as they say in
emily in paris
yes they do um yeah and i'll say connor
uh yeah and if you have a library card
connor i i talked about it last week i
mentioned it this week and helen
peterson's can't even millennials in the
burnout generation speak exactly about
this stuff so
uh check that book out get the audiobook
or if you're flushed with cash buy it
from an independent retailer
but i think that's all the emails and
calls for today right alec yep that's it
awesome so once again please get in
touch with us and also constant shout
out to everyone who calls
and writes an email if we don't get a
chance to get to it it's not because we
don't love it it's not because we didn't
listen to it consider it talk about it
we just have a limited time so please
keep calling keep writing
um two one three five three four eight
eight zero seven culture binge at
wisecrack.co
no m um and in the meantime serbia
if people want to ask you for more
advice recommend stuff to you or see
what you're up to in the next two weeks
where can they find you
serbia patel 22 on twitter
alec if people want your advice or
critical analysis of scientific studies
in literature where can they find you
uh i'm on twitter at wisecrackmalik cool
and i will be uh
live tweeting my journey through the
pesco mediterranean diet at
michael o'burns on twitter um so for me
alec and serbi this has been culture
binge we'll be back in two weeks
subscribe
like review comment and we will see you
next time thanks so much guys
[Music]
you